la universidad de hong kong ha revelado
la baja eficacia de algunas de las
vacunas actuales contra la última
variante omicron sólo 5 de las 25
personas que habían recibido dos dosis
the fighter mostraban después
anticuerpos contra omicron y aún en esos
casos el nivel de protección era hasta
40 veces menor que frente a las
anteriores variantes los resultados de
la vacuna china sinovac son aún más
desastrosos ni una sola de las 25
personas mostraba anticuerpos el estudio
concluye que a la espera de las vacunas
de nueva generación es urgente un tercer
pinchazo de refuerzo la farmacéutica
pequinesa contestaba horas después al
demoledor informe sostiene que según sus
análisis de laboratorio 7 de cada 20
personas sí que muestran de cuerpos y
que en todo caso tras un tercer pinchazo
se alcanza una protección del 94 por
ciento la baja eficacia de las vacunas
actuales ante omicron explica que china
siga fiel a su política de tolerancia
cero contra el coronavirus con medidas
muy estrictas de entrada y cuarentenas
generalizadas cuando surge un solo caso
el estudio de la universidad no solo es
inquietante para china sino para todo el
mundo porque la vacuna china ha sido una
de las más utilizadas en el último año